THERE'S NOEIR FIRST POWER PLAY
GAME ONE
CE.
STONE AGAIN.
PUCK
.
>> HE'S TRYING TTKACHUK.
KEEPS ONGOING, BLOWS B.
HEISKANEN AND HIS STICK SNAPPED
INE SKATES BY PAVELSKI
23% SUCCESSFUL.
AS THE STARS EMERGE WITH IT,
THEY PUSH THE PACECEFLAMES ARE D
GIVE SUTER.
SUTER LONG ONTO IT.
MARKSTROM WAS READY .
THERE'S CERTAINLY A LOT MORE
URGENCY TO THEIR TO HIM AGAIN.
ANDERSSO A LITTLE
LINDELL SHOVELLED ON NETSTROM.
HE'S TRYING TO GET TO HINTZ
FI THE
BLOCKER.
GREAT SAVE RIGHT THERE.
HE JUST TURNED THE LOSING HIS B
REACHINGT SET UP.CHANGE,
GAUDREAU FLYING IN SCORING
OPPORTUNITY.
>> Brendan: SCORE!
HIM FROM RIGHT TO LEFT AND OPEN
UP JUSUS TONIGHT.
THEY HAVE REALLY BEEN ON THEIR .
HINTZ.
LINDHOLMT
PASS, LOOK AT THT THE  UP THE I.
SEGUIN SCORES!THAT IS ON END AN
ABLE T OUT TO CENTER ICE.
BACKLUND WITH AN EMPTY NET